a tres semanas de la derrota el partido
liberal pidió al tribunal superior
electoral de Brasil que anulé los
resultados de la segunda vuelta del 30
de octubre que dieron como ganadora Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el documento de 30
páginas argumenta que unas 350.000 urnas
electrónicas tendrían fallos en el
funcionamiento e impidieron la
reelección de Jair bolsonaro como
presidente
partido liberal este informe no expresa
la opinión del partido liberal sino que
es el resultado de estudios elaborados
por especialistas egresados de una de
las universidades más respetadas del
mundo y que a nuestro entender debe ser
analizado por el Tribunal Superior
electoral
especialistas de utesia pero el tribunal
condicionó de la aceptación de la
demanda a que también se presente un
requerimiento sobre la primera vuelta en
la que se utilizaron las mismas urnas
esto en un plazo no mayor a 24 horas
según el resultado oficial Lula ganó con
un 50.9% frente al 49.1 de evolucionario
en un proceso reconocido por todas las
misiones de observadores nacionales e
internacionales que participaron con el
pedido del partido de liberal
bolsionario podría obtener los votos
suficientes para su reelección por su
parte la presidenta del partido de los
trabajadores de Lula criticó la petición
la actuación de bolsonaro en el tribunal
superior electoral es un artimaña que
debe ser sancionada como litigio de mala
fe no más golpes y responsabilidades
insultos a las instituciones y a la
democracia la elección fue un voto
decidido y Brasil necesita Paz para
construir un futuro mejor
después de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones bolsonaro guardo silencio
público durante casi 48 horas y aunque
no reconoció su derrota se autorizó a su
gobierno a preparar una transición
presidencial